I just am learning this thing vibrates
when I'm supposed to click it fine coast
indicated by spirits all right oh hey
everybody so here come our special guest
for today I'm gonna hey what's going on
ray hey man I married come on sit down
are you take a seat tickets y'all sit on
the end you sit in the middle Dana come
on in sit down yeah Jill how are you sit
down all right everybody wait to the
chat I'm playing this dumb this crazy
Japanese game we couldn't quite figure
out where you take photos yeah I think
it fights ghosts or something anyway
guys welcome ray Dana and Jill match vs.
Evil Dead thank you showed up guys all
right we're gonna get out of this game
and play are you guys big video game
people or no I love video games good it
there we go let me tell you good that's
okay
I don't know five we're about to learn I
love it all right we're gonna play a
game called Luigi's ghost mansion which
is very very fun Willis has broken out
on his own after Mario he's not oh no I
don't know he's got he's got his own
thing he's you know he's the king of the
castle man he doesn't need to prove
himself he's worried Mario I'm thinking
like a Mario Brothers like reboot yeah
[Music]
all right everybody grab a thing here
okay grab a thing here's how this is
gonna work okay I'm gonna be well trade
off but I'm gonna be the ghost actually
would give me this one no I'm sorry okay
so how we're gonna do are gonna play is
no I don't want this
we'll play that later here we go the
ghost I know I'm gonna be a ghost okay
and you guys are gonna try to shine your
flashlights at me all right so everybody
kind of aim the thing oh you need this
okay yeah so everybody I'm a thing I
pick a person here
aim kind of at the screen and pick a
person right there that's me I'm green
here oh yeah you're great
alright I don't know what I am too far
sorry just just pick one of these people
to choose your character doesn't matter
and then hit a good I just have like up
down left right a B yes because these
are very comp that's okay that's okay
do I point in that direct yeah just
point in the dirt just point in the dirt
this is already scary this is already
scary no no here we go alright okay yeah
you could also use this thing I'm gonna
be conscious here we go yes yes are we
did it came over we done that's the game
I'm just kidding yes yes just say yeah
just hit a everybody hit city where'd I
go there we go perfect we did alright
here we go yeah so what is the object
okay the object is okay it's gonna tell
us it's gonna tell us how to play but
here's the deal I'm a ghost
okay that's me with the beard yeah
that's me I kind of look like an easter
egg
I'm so dope oh yeah so everybody turn
their things sideways now this way okay
you're gonna play with the gamepad with
the left right okay right and then the
buttons on yep and then the button on
the right yep there we go perfect
the - it's a - I think yeah it'll tell
you all right so I'm gonna leave the
game ready
so what's gonna happen is I'm a ghost
I'm gonna wander around this this area
and you guys are gonna and I'm gonna be
invisible and when I get close to you
all right when I get close to you your
thing is going to start to vibrate it's
gonna vibrate more and more intense the
closer I am I'm trying to tag you and
you're trying to get me to burn me at
the flashlight no no I do but um what do
you mean ghost or games or people who
are crazy looking like me crazy because
I'm a little upset with myself but just
just the hunt of it all a little off the
sidewalk is an amazing phrase live my
life in the military right now how do we
how do we get you with the flashlight is
there a certain thing we push yeah I
think you you have a flashlight and
you're gonna wander around what happens
when will you come look at that it's
gonna vibrate so this is me so I'm gonna
disappear so it's gonna tell it's gonna
tell us how to play its gets closely
that's a weird horrifying I was like oh
press one to turn yours on okay and all
we do is flash that shiny and you try to
get me you know what's odd is we're
really good at killing Deadites and game
yes we're fine you guys were great with
shotguns it's not so my flashlight when
you come vibrating towards us we flashed
the light yes it's all gonna become
clear in a second talking about clear
we're gonna I don't want to die though
look at this dark creepy old mansion
right guys it's so dark I like it kind
of like it's selling it's just telling
you it's like telling you what it very
sexual very quickly so yeah so shout out
your occasion if some and what do you
guys this is vibrating I'm gonna be
alright
so which players vibrating right oh [ __ ]
get away 218 there's what happened see
you that all wise so I have to press two
to one you're gonna shine it at me yeah
okay so one okay how did you know where
you are
that's the vibrating vibrations
vibrations this is all seems crazy put
in one second it's going on no yo can we
you want to kill me you want to kill me
get the ghost of your life you guys are
trying to find and it'll start vibrating
if I get close to you so I kill you I
kill you with the light though yes also
you only have certain amount of battery
so I wouldn't keep your light on the
whole time all right we can't I kill you
no no no you haven't even yeah okay I
come
[Applause]
[Music]
to be black so you burn you burn me with
your life I did I did ya know if you if
you guys shine that was a way hooray are
you green
I'm glean but I slash the light on you
yeah I get burned I got burned I got you
God but I have a certain amount of life
is not fun if you shine your light on
ray you can revive great thank you
that's me on the phone oh my battery
lights on
go get the battery go get the battery go
get the battery down there he's not
helping
there's your heart oh ok so have I got a
revived me i revived together good keep
doing it today
wait just hold holding on like why
didn't that happen ok what is this guy
doing ok I think he's coming I'll come
get you what I think there's something
you know what I didn't even feel it
vibrate alright let's jump you be the
ghost
you'd be the ghost you know Jesus I got
hit by the thing alright we'll trade off
you revive me how do you guys ever kill
any Deadites you can't work together
it's ridiculous okay
wants to be the ghost who wants to be
the ghost you're gonna get ready buddy
okay here's how you look you just look
at this because you're invisible
when do I appear what how do I appear
you will see yourself the whole time on
here
what do i press so they see me nothing
nothing I mean hopefully only when you
go up to somebody you just go up the top
and that's when it all right I need to
shoot them I know you just are trying to
grab them all right ladies here we go
we're gonna do this all right
here's what I want here's what I want I
want good communication okay you guys
are vibrating let's call it out call it
all right
all right okay we got each other's backs
nobody goes into a room by themselves
none of that way today where's the cat
where's the cat no don't do that don't
follow the cat Newark as no can this
game let's say let's go uh kill ray on
three ready 1 2 kill the ghost 1 2 3 I
thought you video games were like
relaxing it's scary here we go guys
great first game first game we can play
Mario Kart dude go smart no let's keep
right I think raised raised to be a
Greek we're like a contract bred
believing it was a good ghost even
though I'm then the other team I believe
in you always you see here we go
are you ready wait wait you're the
lights guys here otherwise wait hit the
ghost with your light you ready here we
go
all right I'm green I'm green I'm up in
the corner vibrate all right wait all
right
I said communication I think he'll see
you know he's good he's right he's right
to get him oh yeah get it the way you
want to go look how seriously Ray's
taking don't mess with the girls I love
this thank you for arriving welcome here
we go here we go I don't know what's
going on all right here we go he's
getting close he's oh there he is that
lights go down let's go down
are you are you vibrating I'm vibrating
like Oh No
we got on the run
where's the I think he's in the lower
the lower so he's supposed to be
supposed to be there's no dying this
game oh that was great to do one more
round that was good that you got the
hang of it now your old love it alright
let's do it again ready you want to be
the ghost again yeah say alright here we
go okay so tell us a little about ash
vs. Evil Dead alright by the way very
very excited
I love the franchise I'm so the trailer
the tone is perfect very very funny I
can't wait for it what do you got are
you guys excited how many episodes of
you guys shot oh my god I love it
oh that's great it's gonna be a
high-octane fast pace alright is there's
a lot of practical effects right I mean
to the point where it was even though we
all saw the actors before they would get
into debt a Mike uh-huh
they'd be walking around the lunchroom
and I would I would never be Jill and I
would be sitting there like not be able
to eat like oh my god I can't even look
at this person that's terrifying so that
great that crew was so good that's
awesome we have the best crew do you
guys get covered its are you covered in
blood
what are some good tips for getting goo
and blood off yourself Oh funny you
should ask
yeah cuz you're gonna walk here we go
yeah he just said what happening he goes
this is your Joe has a line for it
actually she came up with her own car
be righted word for winds no no damn
what's your copyrighted what gets in
your hair blood gets in your hair
because that's what what happened blood
wood dried nothing could get it out so
they would just cut it out or you know
and then you'd go back and do the scene
and that's what it is nice exactly your
mission that blood is like dead moose I
love it
all right should we do you guys want to
keep playing us or just played Mario
Kart okay everybody loves a good morrow
we did it though we played a scary game
yes what's your question
do you have stars I'm I'm literally
ordering stars very excited I'm gonna
order it through the WiiU is that
possible I don't know no no I'm not even
kidding literally getting it just for
that Jeff well I can't it's
action-packed it does not you blink and
it's like what just happened it's comedy
it's horror it's blood water lighting
what are your favorite horror movies
what kind of influences you guys when
you when you're getting into the mindset
of being afraid what do you think of
well I think of I think of Nightmare on
Elm Street good I wanted I used to set
up like booby traps in the house and I
used to always want to run up those
marshmallow steps yeah yeah and then in
your huddle house turn into like a home
alone situation where there's three
buckets why not gray what do you do
exactly that's crazy that was probably
the first movie that I was like Oh
Exorcist that's just it scared me
because the whole thing that was the
first time I saw like Oh a kid sees an
invisible friend you're like wow and now
it's kind of a trope but like that was
the first one yeah had you read the
Bible at that point no see yeah I had
read the Bible Oh see you knew what was
going on
well I it was scary captain how do you
Bible I don't remember well I mean
anything that's religious based yeah in
my childhood I was just like oh that's
could happen so close to home
yeah so it was horrifying Nightmare on
Elm Street was mine too and because I I
could not sleep
I still could not go back and watch that
movie yeah but I have to say the the one
I could actually watch was the shining
SHINee everybody hit a everybody hit
everyone hit a but I didn't have to even
call in any horror movies cuz I was
legitimately scared and everything that
we filmed in through many a shots
because my my gut reaction was to duck
and then therefore not be on camera and
therefore ruin
oh really that's hilarious and was like
Tina that was great today this take
could you keep your head up so the
camera because I would honestly duck
there's a scene in the first episode of
dead I ham comes to get me and Rudy has
to come save her and I was legit and I
knew it was coming the cast we had that
of you three would have the best chance
if there was a real attack really oh
yeah oh yeah cuz she had no she had have
learned I don't really hold the gun but
she taught us how to I'll hold a gun
basically like this is how you do it
she hasn't look at the video she is like
a proper video and she you were a boxer
she boxing yeah yeah you're like a
sterling she's like oh this ghost I'm so
scared of Lea G's mansion I'm in the
upper leg hey makes you go and
then where my you know way doesn't make
you go yes oh sorry sorry sorry - do I
have to turn with my hands come on Mario
get on it I mean so I'm getting terrible
wait a minute you're up there are you
awake who are you press - there you go
my way no I know that you're stone-cold
killer I'm just like she's now just
pretending pretending and the girl can
got some moves on the dance floor - oh
let's talk about it Dana Dana does a
hair toss I'm trying to win yeah keep
holding - the whole time keep bowling -
the whole time yeah keep holding soon oh
by the way more 11th so I'm doing apps
you know this is you're afraid you want
Jill to win now social I'm horrified
she's well oh yeah Danny at a point yeah
you got a chance of getting all the
points wait no you owe me Oh who's that
I don't know oh how do I throw that
mushroom oh I think it's the trigger in
the back what happens I don't know this
is the opposite of fighting Dana don't
fit we're not gonna see your hair flip
Rosie I want to win right now right
what's your dance move what's your go-to
dance move oh oh he doesn't carry you're
so competitive her hers is like no you
are yours
[Music]
Dana gave me on my birthday
no I just me going like up a thing
you're going like up a hill oh you guys
are killing it oh I just went backwards
by accident oh wait wait wait help
somebody wasn't using you user get this
thing in the No there you go yes that's
it I'm good I'm an eleven Erica left I
am flying single digits is what I'm
asking for
oh man finish already I feel like that
13 year old boy me too whole life oh
love to you Coco we love you too we go
is that terrible rocket punch go I don't
even know okay you got this you got this
you got this
Joe you got you're doing you're doing
you know hit the trigger thing jack i'm
keiko world I think Jill's gonna need to
get this
really we know what we're gonna do any
so measure why why does it go why does
his head hurt why does this head hurt
you know I don't know he's just like
[Music]
guys we all did really well
wait who's Mario oh well done first no
fish I have a question for ya I wanted
to wear a placed well asked but first in
our hearts
Oh first our hurts that you bright guys
in our hearts first up first
well you know it's not about don't worry
about the place it's not about that it's
about how you were so oh you were
bamming up the storm it was amazing okay
that's why is there anything scary yeah
there was a cat that looked kind of
scary which one which cat wait call it
Tina
you call it I think there is back in the
day there is either one but is it
actually something else that's a good
question I don't know I don't know if
thanks I don't know I don't know I don't
know where I am right now I don't know
who this is over here I know what's
going on are you guys there an evil dead
video game let's ask the smart people
based on the movies
exactly basic there is there is I don't
think there it's based on the movies but
I bet there's an army of Darkness one
right maybe there's an army think if
there was Bruce would have made us play
it yeah what guys what was your audition
process like do you have to like no mine
was super weird and awesome what what
tell us about it
well because like literally you always
ask me the question I know I'm genuinely
curious okay when I ask her any
questions it's a tactic cuz I'm trying
to throw him off his game okay no it was
like weird and also too like awesome
like one of the best auditions of my
life in my career
whoa because
typically you don't they ask me to do
action sequences like in an audition
room okay where you would think that
would be a normal Tuesday for an actor
sure but it's not well what do you mean
like action sequences what is that well
like you're shooting things that aren't
there in an office got it coming around
with a gun a fake gun that you're
pretending to have in your hand that's
really tough yeah I do to be fair but
that's I mean that's it I mean you
really have to kind of bars and
producers credit I think that they
wanted to make sure that it was
believable yeah you know so so but it
was so weird but also too so amazingly
awesome but so what how is it so they
didn't ask you to like they normally
would look like pretend to have a gun
install one I'm walking around corners
that don't exist shooting falling down
and I'm doing things that aren't there
that's crudo no but it's awesome
nothing's ever there by the way every
time you see us reacting to something
yeah it's not there it's just an x mark
oh my life is a Deadite which was real
that's gotta be tough that's gonna be
really tough like that's that's when you
really start that's why you guys can do
it and I can't yeah I mean you guys are
accurate actually actors you can act me
too awesome
I'm gonna keep going do it I just want
to keep going yeah oh my goodness in my
audition I I did some pathetic
we're in this wasn't in the show so I'm
not giving anything away but in this and
at the end of the third scene that I to
do they have Pablo hit me in the head
with a frying pan
okay so I just threw myself down like I
got hit in the head with a bribe and the
caster's Christmas it's one of the
reasons I got the job cuz I just threw
myself down and committed almost calms
my setup on my head out on the on the
chair because I'm really a klutz
I like to pretend but I'm Lucille Ball
and can just fall like that but Kelly's
a bad
I love it.tell well you know what let's
tell us a little bit about guys for
people who actually don't know explain
the show and explain your characters
what's the deal okay so I would say that
ash vs. Evil Dead is a continuation to
the Evil Dead franchise you know it's
really about Ash owning up to becoming
the hero that he's always meant to be a
group of people who are trying to escape
there that's what they're running from
themselves and they're their inner
demons and the demons that they come
into contact along the outer inner and
outer yeah and once they face them they
become this ultimate monster fighting
squad that sees the world from evil and
I think the fans are definitely gonna
love it cuz it's a definite like cult
classic comedic horror wrapped up in a
really pretty bloody box with a
half-hour single-camera format God um
and we don't take ourselves too
seriously and I play Pablo Pablo is
Ash's ideal very seriously though
[Laughter]
straight straight people are more
important by the way well I mean like
well I think that amanda has her feet on
the ground right like she's like living
oh I don't even know what I'm doing
right now
none of us do we're just dying about
those guys love it but um Amanda
beautiful description of the show yeah
and by the way navigating postures yeah
that was fun well I'm using a different
art of my brain right now yeah
you're finally unlocking all using all
parts your brain yeah amanda is I choose
a Nolan all badass she you know knows
her way around a gun around a gun she
does
no but she fights for the good guys
she's one of the good ones are we gonna
see enemies that aren't just Deadites oh
you doubt the monster fighting squad
just go off on everybody werewolves
Cardassians you'll see that's absurd for
the Corps - you know hang you for you
guys okay we do a show every day it's
volume business you know there's people
all over there's yeah there's sometimes
even fight themselves which is also very
interesting
whoa when you uh you know Lucy Lawless
his character ruby has has it out for
ash and yeah originally Amanda Fisher
Jill's character thinks he's buying
something so you do not want to mess
with those women because they are
badasses and you will end up without a
face I love on a mission and and Kelly
fits in there she's a little badass in
the making you know she gets ya dragged
into this fight because she's best
friends with Pablo but she is you know
very um she's smart she's tough yeah
she's not afraid to speak her mind yeah
I'm so plain but she also um
you know once she's on once she's on
Team ash she brings common sense to the
group that he needs and and really um
comes into her own and realizes what
she's capable of and and finds this new
kind of dysfunctional family with Pablo
in action that this is what she's been
looking for all along as something to
wake up that's fantastic but it's like
it the show is like like a hilarious
nightmare that you don't want to wake up
from yeah I know it must be really
really fun to go to work everyday just
fight monsters it is great I always say
this when we talk about the show is like
when I was a kid I wanted to be that
person running from the monster yeah I
also wanted to be the hero saving people
from the monsters totally and now as an
adult you know I'm one step closer to
being a superhero I always wanted to be
I've seen oh I'm the first Latino
sidekick on TV whoa I think I don't
think I've ever seen like a horror
sidekick that's been Latino so I'm super
stoked that that's my job if you can
really call it that's awesome not to
mention you know Bruce Campbell yeah
he's back baby I know how is it working
with Bruce
he's a king you know great is that guy
feel like he's hilarious and gregarious
yeah everybody had never met him before
and I was just so stoked to meet him
also to just he's so funny like he off
screen he is on but he's our leader
that's right I'm so really gracious to
us new kids like he yeah he I like to
say took us under his chainsaw away you
know he took us on hikes and talked
about everything and was stories but he
really what he made us felt like we were
meant to be there all along and then but
he sees exactly how you want Bruce
Campbell to be that's a minute I like to
say I like to say he's ham and egg cuz
he's super cheesy no he's super funny
and he tells the best stories no you're
doing good you're doing good
you saw my struggle though no I mean
what's one thing you guys over the
season that surprised you that you
learned doing the show right project
I've been in the genre for a couple of
series other series uh-huh and but I
wasn't like inside the crazy okay kind
of dragged into the crazy what do you
what do you mean inside the crazy
well like American Horror Story Sleepy
Hollow like I was kind of like dragged
in got it got so I was kind of not a
willing participant okay so I'm a
willing participant yes so it's been I
learned so much about myself about how
much I love action and I like a lot of
things I do not put out there I'm not a
gun user yessir in my life I don't want
to like put that out there
you're more nice you like to getting
close do some stabbing what I'm just
saying and just Jill I don't yes I don't
want to put that out there but I
I found power yeah you need a gun is
power kicking butt and shoot the guns
for make-believe I just say it like that
I have to tell ya one of the things I
love about this show too is strong
female characters something in you know
like because you know I obviously grew
up on horror and all that stuff and and
not there were not a lot of strong team
they're always running right exactly one
of the reasons that I really was
attracted to the show is because we're
not waiting on a man to save us right
all three female characters I mean all
all the characters are badasses but the
three female characters because we don't
see that often times yeah yeah and they
go toe to toe with ash which is fun
because it's great he's a good he's a
good good one to go to toe to toe with
CT he knows who he is and he is who he
is yeah so it's fun to see you know them
push each other's buttons totally and
all right one more we're almost done one
more yeah do you want to finish you got
questions for these guys vs. Evil Dead
Jill Rey Dana
hit'em also taking questions on getting
blood out of your hair for this
Halloween season Halloween's coming up
you know whoa oh my gosh that's awesome
I did I don't know like a little watch
do you want to watch your play this time
I'm gonna watch all right I like it all
right you want to watch her play it's
just gonna go me ray no no us three no
he's gonna kill me he's gonna kill me
learn to ride a motorcycle go on uh yeah
I had to learn how to ride a motorcycle
there's a lot of things that were thrown
at me when we got there I mean I did
tell Sam Raimi when I auditioned that I
wanted to run through the wilderness of
New Zealand which is oh you guys shot a
New Zealand Oh
ya ma'bud country yo it's amazing it's
like a backdrop of a postcard that
everywhere that's free Oh
I said look dude completely naked blood
running from Deadites
I will do whatever you want and he's
like that's what I like to hear
oh my god awesome and then and then and
then they threw as many situations as
possible at all of us I think like so I
don't learn how to ride a motorcycle
I had like a jiu-jitsu coach and then we
did harness work really play let's play
us three for the end yeah pick your
person there how do I choose Chewbacca's
dad New Zealand is the Shire yeah
oh god sorry how to do this for
nostalgia sake because Super Mario
Brothers 3 is my was my all-time the
best reach in the hair helps bleach in
the hair helps get the blood out the
fake one no you know when in doubt more
blood more blood gets it up more more
blue oh it's like it's with Gumby for
more coming eventually you shoot the
moon I'm Tom and you're all your hair
falls out I literally probably like
there's an outfit that I don't want to
give too much away but there's an outfit
that I probably had 15 of and different
stages of that that scene thanks today
and like how much blood was on that
scene you know job Oh what are we
touches buckets my boys yet not wait
the blood budget was very high and and
we are we talked about it like I wanted
like what is the blood budget they are
just blood carts
that's all different kinds of blood and
then when in doubt how many times would
we hear on set
can we get more blood more like
meanwhile weird wrench that you barely
can see the whites of our eyes in your
mouth because like it's like it tastes
like soap Oh God I think it tastes like
soap some people it tastes like corn
syrup but it tastes like so oh my god
yeah yeah but like am I going the wrong
way what I think I'm a different person
now
gravy switch oh yeah I think you're down
there you're down there you're done no I
think the fans are gonna love the show
because it's really got like the sense
of nostalgia from the original movies
but it's got sort of a modern edge with
your new kids on the block which are
sitting with you right now
totally and we're giving you no heads
are gonna roll there will be blood
they're all good you're gonna get all
the things that you want from the Evil
Dead movies like you know we got the
Necronomicon yeah we got you know the
crazy Deadites and we got the great
one-liners from the you know iconic
Bruce Campbell there's gonna be a whole
new group of classic ashwin liners look
out for the meme I can't wait come in
you guys have a whole holy book you're
gonna be like whoa that is kind of
actually that is that's a really a point
like because when army of Darkness kind
of came out the internet wasn't a thing
but now it's like the Internet has
adopted that brand of comedy absolutely
you know I mean that that brand of like
comedy or is huge everywhere so I can't
wait to see the match I know it's gonna
be fantastic
they also on on by the way Twitter
follow ash vs. Evil Dead speaking of me
wait let's say you got Dana Lorenz i'm
i'm dana DeLorenzo that was this Jilly
Jones and then real ray Santiago correct
everyone has seen some [ __ ]
hashtag hashtag blood karts oh how much
those Ron if I can just get one black
box yeah hey guys I walk through the
party blood karts over here help
yourself or like
means that they would bring in to sort
of that would know blow the blood on us
no blow in the episode rain I think it
was looked like a snow blower then how
they exploded a lot of things on us you
know Sam you know everyone knows that he
loves torturing Bruce like since they
were 11 is that true yeah they asked he
told a story about how they were a sure
city people dead sorry somebody just
asked they just said when disastrous is
evil dead start October 31st October oh
I just had a seizure Halloween Halloween
on Starz every Saturday at 9 p.m. on
Starz and they'll play it you know a lot
so you'll get to see see it every
Saturday and drop them off and I'm
getting stars for it you should too
I see what you mean we were talking
about video games in the Evil Dead and
I'm just gonna put it out there right
now that I think we should have a neat
ash vs. Evil Dead game like a Jill I
mean well Fischer Kelly Pablo yeah I
mean that's a given and every time you
hit the B button just blood sprays
that's just blood it comes with its own
special like the Kinect camera but it's
just a blood squirt or that and then if
you have you die cuz you have too much
blight on you yeah baby comes out you
get to a certain level then you'll see
exams a man of it with a blade doesn't
work cuz I was like awesome exactly
because he that he's recognized very
early that people laugh when bottom left
what do you wanna stop people laughed
with what and he toured like when he
heard Bruce or like you know when they
were kids a show so it's it's well-known
that that's that Sam likes to torture
again because it gets laughs and it's
funny yeah so to Hebrew still definitely
got it the worst but watching Sam
Raimi's face
while he was there's one scene where
there was a doll that attacks you seen
in the trailer attacks Bruce and Sam
just so they could get the shot had a
practical husband and his face he had
this doll mistake there's a picture of
it out there and his face is like so
enjoying this and Bruce is like so that
was the face he made when he initiated
all of us with our first blood matters
it sounds pretty bad hurts you guys
really hurts you the most but he's and
and it's fun to watch when he doesn't
everyone else and then when he does it
to you you're like oh my goodness okay
that was awesome
the feeling that Sam literally just did
this show so he could torture Bruce
every day he's just writing it so like I
have to say his touch sam raimi yes so
gentle in his directing and of course
he's our boss yeah but his touch is so
gentle in terms of his directing style
like he makes you feel like you're part
of the process yeah he gets his shots
but he's so kind respectful and dream
come true there's a reason why he's a
legend is because of how he carries
himself in his attitude not like Joe
saying how he treats everyone I mean
he's the most unleased intimidating
person in the room oh cool he is sam
raimi and you're aware he's sam raimi
but but he when you talk to him you're
the only one there yeah he does that
with everybody and and I think also he
really wanted to tell the story yes he
wanted a torture booth but you know the
fans have been asking for 30 years yes I
know
he's really he's really about the
passion of telling the story and I think
anybody that cares that much about
something and yours for the fans you're
gonna get a great product and I think it
comes to my camera too because it's like
everybody it is scary but it's also
really playful and fun I don't think you
could
just you are that person yes exactly
nail is well guys thank you for coming
this is fantastic
into the renzo ray Santiago and Jill
Jones watch ash vs. Evil Dead Halloween
9:00 p.m. please and find out if there's
a Evil Dead game out there this is what
someone ps2 has an evil dead there we go
perfect one point we'll play it sometime
in the future thank you guys for showing
up and thank you guys for watching
you